الان سنتحدث مشاهدينا عن الحاجه الفنلنديه
لدخول حلف شمال الاطلسي بانها ليست احاديه
الجانب بل طبعا هي متبادله المنافع
للطرفين اذا انضمام فنلندا للنيتو يضيف
للاخير جيشا قويا ويضاعف طول حدوده مع
روسيا وبالتالي طبعا يساهم بتعزيز
الدفاعات جناحه الشرقي في مواجهه اي هجوم
روسي هل سنكي تمتلك جيشا كبيرا بالنسبه
لعدد سكانها وحجمها في اوروبا فما يقرب من
ثلث السكان البالغين فيها هم من جنود
الاحتياط هي قادره على حشد 280 الف جندي
في زمن الحرب والاعتماد على احتياطيه يبلغ
بالاجمال 870 الف جنديا فهي من الدول
الاوروبيه القليله التي ابقت على نموذج
التجنيد الاجباري كما ايضا تمتلك واحده من
افضل ترسانات المدفعيه في اوروبا مع 1500
قطعه مدفعيه ضخمه وذاتيه الحركه فيما
قوتها الجويه ايضا تقوم بالاساس على نحو
خمس وخمسين طائره اف18 الامريكيه الصنع مع
التعاقد على شراء 64 طائره من طراز اف 35
اضافه طبعا الى كل هذه القدرات العسكريه
من شان فنلندا توفير مزايا جغرافيه رئيسيه
تعزز دفاعات الناتو فحدود فنلندا مع روسيا
تمتد لاكثر من
1280 كيلومترا وستساهم بتقريب الحلف اكثر
الى شبه جزيره كولا الروسيه علما بان كولا
هي ارض استراتيجيه تقع على بعد
177 كيلو مترا شرق الحدود وهناك تحتفظ
روسيا بغواصات الصواريخ الباليستيه وايضا
الرؤوس الحربيه النوويه واي ضا يتمركز
الاسطول الشمالي اذا انضمام فنلندا الى
النيتو وربما السويد لاحقا قد يغير المشهد
العسكري من البلطيق الى القطب الشمالي اذا
لدينا قوه ردع للحلف يقابلها مخاوف من
التصعيد مع روسيا التي تشكل اراضيها اكثر
من 50% من ساحل المحيط المتجمد الشمالي
[موسيقى]